tell me lies has exploded on social
media and just seeing these tweets that
are steamy and just wild in the best way
possible have do you check out social
media I don't I haven't read anything
I've been sent some crazy hilarious
tweets that make me laugh so hard but no
I'm not willingly looking because it
scares me well I'm hoping you might
willingly look right let's do it
attention do not watch tell me lies on
Hulu unless you've got someone you can
booty call
this is not for the lonely oh my God oh
my God what do you make of that I mean
yeah right how can you not watch Lucy
and Steven but that's interesting
because I feel like I would watch him be
like no no man no no nobody Shield
yourself from that protect me please
pillows and blankets
oh
tell me lies is giving me toxic
relationship
boy Taylor Swift All Too Well messiness
vibes
[Music]
I mean that's a huge compliment right
there oh my God boy Taylor Swift All Too
Well messiness Vibes and I'm here for it
I love it
no one can convince me that Grace Van
Patten Lucy isn't a love child of
Shailene Woodley and Leighton Meester oh
I'll take that do you ever get that I
get Shailene Woodley all the time okay
Leighton Meester is a new one but Gossip
Girl Is my
forever right I will take that haven't
you heard I'm a crazy [ __ ] around here
have you met either of those ladies I
just recently met chalene for the first
time did you have a moment about I told
her I was like she was so so sweet and
I'm like I get compared to you all the
time it's the biggest compliment ever
and she was so sweet she was awesome we
need a cameo in season two oh my God my
sister Lucy has a secret twin sister
that we didn't know about oh my God is
she amazed and Steven starts dating her
oh my God
whoa this opening sex scene was a little
too spicy for me hashtag tell me lies
you don't hate me do you ever feel like
we are pushing the sexy meter a little
too far it's it's sexy yes and there
were some sex scenes that we even cut so
it was it was gonna be even even more
what did we not see there was supposed
to be in episode six when Stephen
confesses to being in the car with Macy
and he's crying and we're in that
Greenhouse we were supposed to have sex
after that and
okay and then we were reading it and I
was like I don't know if this this is
the right moment for that and Megan was
like absolutely done so there was
supposed to be one there
#tell me lies being about Long Island
kids and their families a chef's kiss
for me at the moment
wow yeah I mean that's accurate Long
Island kids with no accents though Cold
Spring Harbor baby if Lucy like talked
like this that'd be so funny
Stephen and tell me lies is so toxic but
my God he is so hot I'd let him ruin my
life in a second
I imagine you might hear that out in
public a few times Jackson great work on
the show you can ruin my life anytime
thank you thank you nice to meet you
[Music]